What did you find, David?
>> So we've got A right here and
Y right here.
We've got a line that goes through
the two that differentiates them
that roughly lines up with 2E.
So I said 2E.
>> That looks like a good answer to me.
Recall that when we were using the table
to organize the case memory previously,
we were very concerned that this side
of the table would grow very large.
It will become very difficult to search
for a specific case in that table.
The potential answer to that.
By asking a question we are quickly
able to prune away one part of the tree.
That makes this search
process much more efficient.
And that's the point of
the discrimination tree.
In both organizational scheme,
the table and
the discrimination tree, we are trying
to accommodate and accumulate new cases.
But in the case of the discrimination
tree, by asking the right
questions to the right nodes, we make
the search process more efficient.
>> So for those of you
familiar with big O notation,
you'll notice that the efficiency of
searching the case library organized
by indices was linear,
whereas here it's logarithmic.